PO ON THE
BARRETT.
>>E , S NOMINATIITE LVG D NTO TM
WASASNGG RES THATPORNOGRAPHIC T
I WANTED T
SENATOFR MISSOURI  HISOUPO
JUSOETN NDERS OFE
SHE HAS BEENINSCHOOLYOT RIR M CE
ENDANG
GHT ABOUS CHARGES AS I
WAAMILLIG
WHATT IT MHAD ON PERSO K
PARENNDS WEEAENTATION
OF TLAW, SENTENCING, EDYO
ROD AT THAT PO YOU, SENATOR. MOO
DSE CASES, I
WAINKING THA
BE FROE H.MEST
DIFFICULT CASES THAT A JUDGE HAS
TO DEAL TH, LK
CHILDRE WKI
C DESCRIPTIONS THA
WHEN THEY DECIDE HSE
THEY'RE SUPPOS H DECAT IN AN
DO THETUTE, TH S
ELTOPOTYOR
E AT NING AN
AND IN EVERYASALIMPOSE STE SUFFT
CIS, IT IPOE TO
HILDREN'
LOOKERT D  REPRESENTNGWH TT MEAT
THINGS ON TEE,L TH
CTE
CO.T THAR ABUSE O TELLE Y
WIER HAVE A NOLTRELATIONIPS
ABUSE.
FELL INTS BECATHATWAS S ANNF
MOST G TO ME  ONE OF THESE
SENTENCINGS WHENOOK  FENDANT INE
FOREVER. MERHER  S THAT STORY T
SO TEY UNDERSTANWHATTHEYAVE DONE
CONTRIBUTING TCHILE EN IOSA SIG
'T USE TOMPUTE AMAR MPOF
TCRIME >>L HEES
FROMRERRDASU
INCARCERATIO S
SPDEFENDANT,UR CRIMINAL  SAS BEN
OF, YOU HED IT IND THE IMPACT OL
CRIME AMONTHENSE THIT HAS
ENTENCED.
SO THEOUOO  CLLCYN THAT DEFENDA.
AS SENATOR SAI
BELI T
BHE ADDRESSIG LT  LGEAR MBERS
NO TLUMINOUSUNOFL HA
THE JUDICIARY, ASENTEN I
Y'AS A QUEST
CING
TH CS,
N ATT D , ING
THE OPERATION OF THIS GUIDELINE.
AS YOU SAIUIDELINE WASIGINALLY
SPECIFIC DGR
ORRIOUS ILD POWEREIDENTIFIED BAA
E DIDN'T
INTERN, DN
DISTRIBUTION, THE THE INE ISHACN
EXTREME DISPARITIES  THE
SEE WAY ITCAUSE IT IS SO EME IS
, AND PES EVEN IN HAS TAKEN THAT
G THEIR SENTENCES NT TCIRCUMSTAE
ABCNEWS, ASD OTHECO
THATHEINACTEU INIRON ONE WRITER
ARE METLHE OACCEPTTI2019ONLYNON
OFFENDERS RECEIVED A SENTENCE
FEWETH 30%.INES
2015 IN TH
T, WEL
NONPRODUCTION CASES 80% OF THE
STATE OF THE SENATOR W HRD, DIDT
ONE IC
SENATOR SUTETO BECOME A E BYMENT
P, U
S SOMAKE SURE THS
HERE IT TH- INTED JUDGE Y, THE T
SENTEND NVSELDRAY 0 MONTHS, LL
TH MENDED BY TH
E N INTO THESS THAT
YOU HAVECRIBED GMST WE AT
E THE Y YOUR AE
SETTING PENALTIES.
COREGES WHTEAT I
CONGRESS HAS TO DETERMINE UD HD
BUT ASENE ATS  THE CONGRES MI
RITYNOT NSNTHESE CRIMEND THEREF